i'd like to thank lab roots for their
invitation to present our work
i wanted to talk to you about new
checkpoints and biomarkers
these are my disclosures
now immunology has offered hope for
curing cancer for over 100 years but up
until the last
eight years you couldn't go into your
doctor's office and get a reliable
anti-cancer immunotherapy but that's
changed
and what's changed
now
is that we have a new strategy
and that strategy
is to stop the tumor from turning off
the immune response
and that's been termed
checkpoint blockade
the revolution in cancer immunotherapy
has come from our deeper understanding
of the second signals that regulate the
outcome of t cell receptor signaling
now specificity is provided by the
recognition of the t cell receptor of an
asgenic peptide in association with mhc
a positive co-stimulatory signal is
provided by the interactions of the b7
molecules cd80 and 86 with the cd28
receptor on t cells
and this results in
signaling which results in optimal t
cell proliferation
cytokine production and cytolytic
activity
the surprise was that there are negative
second signals
we identified
the pdl1
and pdl2 molecules and showed they
interacted with pd1
pd1 cytoplasmic domain became
phosphorylated and recruits the
phosphatase shp2 which results in
dephosphorylation of the proximal
signaling molecules of the t cell
receptor
and cd28 pathway and this results in
reduced t-cell proliferation cytokine
production and cytolysis
we made this discovery about 20 years
ago in a collaboration of three labs my
lab clive woodlaw woods lab at the
genetics institute and tosuko hanjo's
lab in kyoto and this identifies the
drug target
to block the pdl1 pd1 pathway and first
showed that pdl1 could be expressed in
an ovarian tumor
blockade of the pd-1pd l1 pathway can
unleash an anti-tumor t cell response
it results in enhanced activity of
effector t cells such as increased
killing by cytolytic t cells and
increased production of cytokines like
gamma interferon
this has led to clinical translation and
there are now multiple pdl1 and pd1
drugs
these have been
tested in
multiple clinical trials and are now fda
approved in 21 different types of tumors
this actually represents it's estimated
about 43 percent of cancer patients are
eligible for a pdl-1 or pd-1
immunotherapy
the pd1 immunotherapies do not work
everywhere
they don't work in glioblastoma
pancreatic or colorectal which don't
have mismatch repair deficit they can
work from a high of 87
response rate in hodgkin's lymphoma
to a low approved rate of 13 in gastric
averaging about a 20 to 30 percent rate
in most of the common solid tumors
there's clearly room for improvement
now the future is clearly combination
therapies
pd-1 blockade is the foundation to build
upon and it can be combined with
blockade of other immuno inhibitors
kinase inhibitors or chemotherapies
angiogenesis blockade tgf fader or hdac
inhibitors
pd-1 blockade plus immunostimulators
cancer vaccines oncolytic viruses or car
t cells more novel agents such as
probiotics
or nutrients
in fact there's over 300 different
combination therapies which have been
tested in mouse and found to enhance the
response to pd-1 immunotherapy and these
are now
being developed and tested in people
clearly not all of the combinations are
going to work
the ones highlighted in red have been
tested
worked and are now fda approved and
include pd-1 blockade plus ctla-4
or pd-1 blockade plus cisplatins or nab
paplataxel or angiogenesis blockade
despite
good preclinical evidence
phase three trials of pd1 blockade plus
ido neck inhibitors
or colony stimulating factor receptor 1
did not
do sufficiently well in phase 3 trials
so they're not all going to work
so where does checkpoint blockade
function
now it's believed that ctla4 primarily
works in the lymph node this comes from
the idea that the b7 molecules are
primarily expressed on
activated antigen presenting cells very
rarely on a tumor
and that
the interaction of c-tail it for
antibody blocks the interaction with b7
in contrast
pd1 was initially thought to work
primarily in the tumor because pdl-1 can
be expressed on many tumors also antigen
presenting cells stromal cells myeloids
derived suppressor cells
pd1 can be expressed on the t cell
however we also now realize that pdl1 in
the lymph node is also important and can
be expressed on astrin presenting cells
in the lymph node so pd-1 is important
in both
now
ctla-4
blockade works by the antibody binding
to ctla4 and preventing the interaction
of ctla4 with b7
this removes the higher interaction
in affinity interaction of ctla4 with
the b7s
and it results in unopposed
stimulation of b7s through cd28
now it's also been shown in mouse models
by alan corman and others
that ctla4 antibody can bind to and
deplete t regulatory cells which express
high levels of ctla4
however this hasn't been shown despite
considerable effort
in
uh people
now it's important to completely
understand the function of the pd-1
pathway
and we asked what was the function of
pd1 on regulatory t cells
and the take home lesson of this section
is going to be
that pd1 is an equal and opportunity
inhibitor of t cell function
loss of pd1 on t effector cells can lead
to stronger t effector cells
but to our our surprise
loss of pd-1 on t regs
actually makes more suppressive t
regulatory cells
and this is the work of catherine tan
and juhi gutru in arlene shark's lab
where we made the
conditional pd-1 knockout and this is
recently published in the journal of
experimental medicine
now
the approach
was to selectively knock out pd1
only on regulatory t cells and to do
this we used fox p3 cree
in a phlox pd1 allele
and this inducibly deletes pd1
on t regs in adult mice
now
t regulatory cells
can work by multiple interactions to
suppress the activity of both dendritic
cells and t effector cells
the t regs can express high levels of
ctla4 and bind and remove cd80 and cd86
the cd39 and cd73 molecules on t regs
can convert atp into immuno-inhibitory
adenosine
the il-2 receptor can compete for il-2
and t-regs can make suppressive
cytokines such as aisle 35 grand sign b
il-10 and tgf beta
now when katherine made
t-reg's
depleted in pd-1 she tested them in an
in-vitro t-reg suppression essay and
found that t-rigs lacking pd1 are more
suppressive than wild-type t-rigs
here in the black line is wild type t
effectors alone and this is a cell
tracker violet
assay of
t-cell division and you can see the
wild-type effectors divide well
in blue is the wild type effectors plus
control wild-type t-regs that express a
normal amount of pd1
and they suppress
but if the t regs are depleted of pd-1
if as shown in red
the t-regs deplete even or
suppress
even better
and this was also seen in vivo
in nod mice lacking pd-1 selectively on
the t-regs
they're protected from type 1 diabetes
normally non
as shown in blue
wild type nod mice with normal amounts
of pd-1 on the t-rex
develop
diabetes as they age
in contrast
if the nod mice lack pd-1 on their
t-regs as shown in red they don't
develop diabetes as they age
um they have a higher percent
of um
fox p3 cells
in the pd1 depleted
the percentage of proliferating cd8 t
cells goes down in the pd-1 deficient
mice
and the percentage of cytokine producing
cdat cells making gamma interferon and
tnf goes down in the pd1 deficient t-reg
population mice
now in another model of autoimmunity eae
inducible deletion of pd-1 and t-reg's
before disease induction again
attenuates
eae
as shown in blue
normal mice with pd-1 on the t-regs
develop of
eae but in contrast
if
the
t-regs are lacking in pd1 they develop
less severe eae
now transcriptional analysis and
analysis of fossil akt
showed that pd-1 deficient t-regs have
reduced pi3 kinase akt mtor signaling
the hallmarks of
the ti3 kinase signaling pathway
were
less in pd-1 deficiency rigs higher in
wild-type t-regs
similarly the phospho-akt
as shown on the right
in blue in wild-type t-cells you've got
phospho-akt but in the pd-1 deficient
t-regs there was less fossil akt
now it's known and has been published by
krellen and others that increase pi3
pathway activity results in reduced
t-reg suppressive capacity
and we wondered uh whether this
pathway was what was resulting in the
increased t-reg function
now pi3-kinase akt signaling regulates
glycolysis and mitochondrial functions
and here
it's shown that
pd1 deficient t-regs are less glycolytic
here in red you can see they have a
lower
extracellular acidification rate in a
seahorse assay
and the glycolytic capacity
is less in the td1 deficient t-regs and
they have less glycolytic reserve
similarly
the pd-1 deficient t-regs have an
increased
mitochondrial function you can see uh
here in red
they have an increased oxygen
consumption rate
increased spare respiratory capacity and
increased maximal
oxygen consumption rate
consistent with increased mitochondrial
functions
now
if this is the case um increasing phosph
akt activity should reverse this
and
here in the middle you show the
condition without an akt agonist and
indeed the pd-1 deficient
um t-regs are less suppressive
more suppressive
but
um if
they're treated with an akt agonist
the amount of suppressive capacity of
wild-type or pd1 deficient t-regs is
lost and both
suppress equally efficiently
so in summary of this section what i say
is that pd1 restrains both t effector
activity as is well known
but
to our
somewhat surprised
cd1 also restrains t-reg activities
so pd-1 on t-regs limits their
activation and suppressive capacity and
if you lose or block pd-1 you get
better suppressive activity
now this coordinates very well with some
recent papers from the nishikawa lab
in nagoya
and they found that pd-1 blockade
reinvigorates dysfunctional pd-1cda t
cells
and enhances pd-1 t-reg suppressive
activity in tumors
now
there have been a few reports of
hyper-progressive disease which occurs
when pd-1 blockade
can actually activate or expand
tumor-infiltrating pd-1-t rigs and this
overwhelms the pd-1 effector t-cells and
actually results in a worse clinical
outcome to pd-1 blockade
and the tumors of these rare
hyper-regressive patients had highly
proliferating fox p3t rigs which
contrasts with the reduction in
non-hyperprogressive tumors
now
the important thing for biomarker
development is that the nishikawa lab
showed that the frequency of
pd-1-positive cd8-t cells
to pd-1-positive t-regs in the tumor
microenvironment can predict the
efficacy of pd-1 blockade therapies
providing a possible
biomarker
what it also suggests is that depletion
of these t-regs may help treat or
prevent hyperprogressive disease
now cti 4 block key
is one of the best combinations with
pd-1 blockade but it's been somewhat of
a mystery why it works particularly well
and this may give some reason for why
it's because ctla 4
targets t regs rather preferentially
so if pd1 blockade
makes stronger
t-regs the ctla-4 can actually remove
these more active t-regs
resulting in a particularly valuable
combination
it also suggests that development of
agents such as by specific antibodies
that target pd1 on t effector cells but
not t regs might be even more effective
than the standard pd-1 ctla4 amplitudes
what are additional checkpoints that
could be targeted for cancer
immunotherapy
the b7 pathway has been a rich source of
cancer immunotherapy targets with pdl-1
pdl2 ctla-4 blockade developed vista
agents icos agents are in uh development
b7h3 and h4 agents are in clinical
trials
and we noticed that there was another b7
family member called hhla 2.
it was known to have one receptor tmi
gd2 with a stimulatory
activity but there were suggestions that
there was also an inhibitory receptor
um we looked at hhla2 expression and
other v7s in normal kidney versus clear
cell renal carcinoma
and this analysis done by sam freeman
compares
um
in reddish
normal kidney and in blue
rcc
and what we saw very quickly
was that hhla2 was highly upregulated in
rcc pdl1 is just a little upregulated
pdl2 a little more
p7h3 upregulated
surprisingly b7h4 was down regulated
um
vista upregulated a little bit icos
little change
um there's lots of cd8 t cells uh in rcc
it's highly inflamed
so this said that hh la2 might be a good
target
and indeed we found hhla2 expressed in
multiple uh tumor types
high in renal pancreatic
adenocarcinoma the lung and colorectal
high in aml
um not in some other tumors
we made an immunohistochemistry antibody
uh as has zing zing zhang
and we found that some rcc didn't
express any hhla2 but that some
renal carcel
tumors
definitely expressed hhla2 on the
surface of the tumor cells
when we examined
with sabina signoreti and rupaulbot
of hhla2 and pdl1 expression in
rcc what we found
is that they weren't co-expressed
if they were co-expressed and each dot
here is
um
one
immunohistochemistry of one tumor
and what we see is we've plotted a pdl
one score or an hhla two score of each
tumor
if they were co-expressed
they would be out here in the upper
right quadrant but in contrast
the pdl1 scores
are all
along the left axis
there's not much shift to the right
indicating hhla2 expression
similarly the hhla2 if they express
highly
do not move up in pdl1 score
so they're not
co-expressed
in a rare tumor where we found that pdl1
and h802
were both expressed
they were expressed in different areas
this is
sequential sections by
immunohistochemistry
on the left is immune histochemistry of
hhla2
and you can see it's expressed in this
tissue down to the lower left
but
and in the next section we stain for pdl
one you can see it's expressed in this
section up in the upper right
and you can see that the areas
don't correspond to cross expression
now
we also found that hhle2 is regulated
very differently than pdl1
gamma interferon is well known to
upregulate pdl1
and here in this um
renal cell carcinoma line 786 pdl1
indeed upregulates
it's in the interferon
definitely upregulates pdl1 expression
however interferon doesn't upregulate
hhla2 expression so they're
differentially regulated
now the chen
and zhang labs have shown the tmig d2
is
a
receptor for
hhla2 and can result in akt
phosphorylation and can stimulate t cell
t-cell
activation
but there was also reports of an
inhibitory
interaction
of hhla2
so we did a screen with retrogenics
using hhi2 fusion protein and found that
hhla2 bound specifically to cure 3 dl3 a
killer inhibitory receptor
now
the cure family is composed of 15 of
different members
and we went back and individually
examined
the binding of hhle2 to each of the 15
tiers
and this is done
uh
by transfecting 293 t cells
and incubating them with hhla 2 fc
fusion protein if they bind you get a
black to the dark spots duplicates
and you can see that the hho2xc
binds to c3dl3
and its known receptor tmigd2
but
doesn't bind to
any of the other here family members
or to pdl1 or pd1
and the affinity
for of hhla2 for cure 3
and tmigd2 is a similar
now the cure 3dl3
um cytoplasmic domain
has
an itin motif
um just one motif
consistent with an immuno-inhibitory
function it has three ig domains in its
extracellular domain
it's also unusual among the cure family
um in that it's what's called a
framework here many of the cures are
lost in different individuals but the
cure 3dl3 is always maintained and
expressed
we made hhle2 antibodies that block
hhla2 binding to kier 3 dl3
and we also made
two hh two antibodies which are
selectively uh blockers of tier three
but not tmi gd2
we also and we also made tier three
antibodies that block hhla2 binding to
tier three
and also antibodies that don't block
now we then examined kir3dl3 expression
which is pretty rare on t cells
we activated
t cells
with myogen
and looked at the expression of tier 3
dl3
it's not expressed rapidly but after a
while it's expressed on a moderate
percentage of activated t cells
we then tested the effect of tier 3 dlc3
signaling in a jerkid il2 reporter assay
making a jerk at t cell uh expressing t
cell receptor and tier 3 dl3
and an
artificial antigen presenting cell
um a cho cell uh transfected with a
single chain
uh fd anti-cd3 antibody
and
hhla2
and this uh then drives the il-2
promoter driving luciferase
and so it's a luciferase readout for t
cell activation
and we showed that
in this system cd 28 results in up
regulation of
t cell activation as expected
um but if the ch astron presenting cell
expressed hhla2
this activation by cd
3 and cd 28 was greatly reduced
so this shows that the cure 3dl3 is
indeed an immunoinhibitory pathway
and this was published
recently um by rupaul bach and other
members of the lab
and collaborators in cancer immunology
research
now we then uh looked at the effect of
blocking antibodies in this t cell
activation antigen
and here in blue
and red
we're looking at the fold t cell
activation so a rise shows that the
antibody is blocking the pathway
resulting in
enhanced t cell activation and indeed
the three antibodies that block the
interaction stimulate t cell activation
here the hhla2 antibody that doesn't
block the interaction has no effect
so the mechanism of action seems to be
blockade
similar to the cure three antibodies the
two that block the interaction enhanced
t-cell activation the antibody that
didn't block had no effect
now we then tested the effect of tier 3
dl3 signaling in an nkt cell cytosis
assay
um
the nk cells we used are
the nk92 mi cells
these are
mk92 cells transfected with il2
and they constitutely uh express high
levels of cure 3dl3 in contrast to the
parental nk92 cells which don't express
hardly any
so we found that tier 3 dl3 engagement
by hh2
inhibits nk cytosis
here you can see that a k562 cell
is killed by the nk92 mi cells but that
it expresses hhla2
the cell is killed less efficiently in
each
effector to target ratio
similarly another target cell rajis raw
g cells with beta 2
microglobulin knocked out
show the same pattern
we also found that the cure iii dl3 and
hhl2 blocking antibodies
enhanced nk lysis
um here you can see
um
in the dark colors the control and in
the brighter colors the antibody
blockade
and you can see that the blocking
antibodies enhance the cytolysis
in blue the non-blocking antibody does
not
so our model
um here
is that
the
hhla2 can interact with tmigd2
and in naive t cells have a stimulatory
role
but that
in
certain
tumors or antigen presenting cells the
interaction of hhla2 and tier 3
inhibits t-cell activation cytolysis and
cytokine production in a dominant way
and that blockade of this tier 3 hhla2
pathway
would enhance an anti-tumor immune
response
so in summary hhla2 is a ligand for
q3dl3
which is an inhibitory receptor
expressed in activated t cells and nkt
cells
um blockade of this pathway can enhance
t and nk activity
hhi2 is expressed in the majority
of clear cell renal cell carcinomas
and
hh-72 expression
is
non-overlapping with pdl1 expression
hhl2 is highly expressed in multiple
pdl1 negative
tumor types
so
the hhlet pathway is expected to impact
a large proportion
of
the
pd1 refractory patients potentially
now there are multiple challenges for
developing
agents in the hhle 2 tier 3 pathway
the cure 3 dl3 expression is relatively
rare
indicating that this must be
a powerful or highly regulatory t cell
for the immune response in order to have
a pivotal role
the other
challenge to
translating this
is that the hhla2 tier 3 and tmigd2
genes are not expressed in rodents
one member of the pathway is
was lost then the others
and so you can't do a mouse model you
would have to add all three
genes back to make a model
um
so you can't do it directly in roses
it's expressed in subhuman primates and
multiple other mammals so those are
possibilities
but there isn't an orthologous mouse
model
so we're going to have to model this in
humanized mouse
or human xenograph tumor models in mice
and we're really exploring what are the
best ways to model
a purely human pathway
in
individual models in mice or other
species and i'd be interested in your
thoughts
on that matter
so in closing i wanted to basically talk
briefly about the what i think is the
future of cancer therapy decisions
and i think this is a combination of
personalized medicine and immunotherapy
we do want to sequence every tumor
every patient should be tested for tumor
mutational burden
because this will identify
tumors that are likely to be more
responsive indeed mismatch repair
deficient tumors
such as msi in colorectal
um they can represent about 15 percent
of colorectal about four percent of
total tumors
and these can have a 40 to 62 response
to rate two pd-1 immunotherapy
the other thing that sequencing will
tell us is whether there's pdl1 or pdl2
genomic amplification
this
occurs as shown by margaret shipwreck
and philippe armand in virtually all
hodgkin's lymphoma
and those have an exceptionally high
rate
of response to pd-1 immunotherapy 87
because they're fundamentally addicted
to the pdl-1 pdl2 immuno inhibition
um while common in hodgkin's lymphoma
it does occur
in one to two percent of other total
tunes
sequencing will also tell us whether the
tumor is expressed expressing viral
antigens and indeed the immune response
is most
designed to respond to foreign antigens
such as papillomavirus
as can be found in merkel cell lymphoma
or head and neck
sequencing tumors will also identify
actionable mutations which will allow
the use of targeted kinases or salt
cycle inhibitors
it'll also identify the neoantigens
which can be developed for cancer
vaccines
this will let us choose
uh and analyze the tumor micro
environment uh and profile it
to look at pdl1 expression
other mechanisms of immune evasion such
as ido tgf beta b7h4
cellular matrix or other mechanisms of
immunoinfiltrate
and also measure how much cd8 and
other immune cells are in
filtrating into the tumor
there's also great progress being made
in indivo imaging of pdl1 expression or
cd8 immune infiltration into tumors
we're also
rapidly being able to look at tumor dna
in the blood and tell a surprising
amount about the whole tumor in the body
and what's happening this will allow us
to choose the best immunotherapy and
combine it with the best targeted
therapy or vaccine
i think it's a really exciting time to
be an oncologist or researcher because
you can bring greater benefit to
patients
the pd1 pdl one blockade pathways work
on a wide variety of tumors with a
moderate percentage of responders and a
good safety profile
it gives us a good foundation to build
on
and
with this
success
um really your human creativity has been
unleashed
and you're going to get to do the
experiments which will really show us
um what works
what's safe how it works
and who it will work for
um these are the members of my lab
who've done the work over the lab uh
including julia brown quaffan kai yen
ping xiao kathleen mahoney sanju apoorvi
chaudhry sarah klein america
also i'd like to acknowledge my many
collaborators
over the years
really always beginning with arlene
sharps lab in the investigation of b7
family members
the t-reg work i showed today is a
collaboration primarily uh done by
catherine khan juhi cuchu and pete sage
the
the hhla2 work
uh is primarily done by abdullah burgess
and kathleen mahoney um with the collect
strong collaboration of rupal bots lab
at the bi dmc with julia kong chung hwa
chen
uh and david mcdermott for rcc
and uh the pd-1 pdl-1 works really
begins with the identification of
pathway with clive wood and to sukho
hanzo
thank you i'd be
happy to take further questions